okay so the topic of our video today is
one of the four categories of organic
molecules
you know lipids are one of the four
categories as are carbohydrates proteins
and nucleic acids I have a separate
video for carbohydrates proteins and
nucleic acids if you're interested but
today we're gonna focus on the category
of organic molecule called lipids so
let's get started okay so as we go into
our discussion on lipids no lipids are
what make up fats oils and waxes now
lipids kind of have a negative
stereotype a negative connotation of
them because we hear the word lipid and
we see it's associated with fat and we
think it's unhealthy and horrible and
zero fat is good well here's a couple
reasons on why biologically we need fats
fats provide energy for cells so we can
break down fats and get get ATP energy
from them through the process of
cellular respiration lipids make up part
of our cell structure you might know
that phospholipids make up our
phospholipid bilayer the outer boundary
of every single cell in our body you
look at this picture right here of an
elephant seal well this elephant seals
very fat it has a thick layer of blubber
which is a great insulator for it it
swims in very cold ocean waters and so
has to be able to keep itself warm so
lipids are very much a needed part of
our diet we just don't want to of course
overdo it and put ourselves at heart at
risk of health effects so when we look
at the cell membrane here we have the
blue double phospholipid bilayer right
here in this picture and our cell
membrane the boundary of every single
cell in our body is composed of a layer
a dual layer of lipids called
phospholipids so there's another reason
why-y-y lipids are just really biola
biologically important they composed the
bound outer boundary of our cells and
embedded within our cell membrane is
another type of lip
called cholesterol again cholesterol
kinda has a negative image negative
stereotype to it because we see the drug
commercials with you know medications
designed to lower our cholesterol but we
need a healthy amount of cholesterol it
gives the cell membrane its flexibility
it prevents the phospholipids from
bunching up too much or spreading apart
too far so we really need a normal
healthy level of various lipids so when
we look at the structure of a lipid I
want to start with a collection a small
grouping of atoms on the top of the
molecule this that's why I call it the
head and this small collection of atoms
is what we call a glycerol molecule and
I've just simply shown it as this blue
circle and attached to the head attached
to the glycerol head it will be a couple
maybe three or so chains of what are
called fatty acids dangling down from
them and so in this picture I have two
chains of orange fatty acids dangling
down but you may have heard of what it's
called a triglyceride the reason it's
called a triglyceride tri means three
triglycerides have three chains three
tails of fatty acids dangling down from
them so lipids don't always have to
sometimes they have more than two chains
of fatty acids well this is a very
simplistic picture right here here's a
more realistic picture of what a lipid
might look like this is actually a
phospholipid so not only does it have a
head made from a molecule called
glycerol but there's also another
molecule called a called a phosphate
group well we'll talk more about that if
you watch my cell membrane video but
there's a clump of molecule a clump of
atoms at the top called the head and
then you can see there are two tails of
fatty acids dangling down in this
picture and we mentioned in another
video that organic molecules are made
from monomers and polymers and so the
polymers have believed just what the
overall object is the lipid and the
lipid is made from smaller parts called
fatty acids and you can even add
glycerol to that fatty acid endless
would be the monomers well let's move on
so I want to mention he probably heard
of some fats called saturated and other
fats called unsaturated I want to
mention the difference here's a picture
of a saturated fatty acid I just
mentioned that lipids are made from a
glycerol head and a fatty acid tail well
some of those tails are what we call
saturated fatty acids and others are
unsaturated fatty acids so let's first
of all look at saturated fatty acids
notice how there's a long chain of
carbon-carbon single bonds anytime you
see a carbon bonded to another carbon
there's a single bond in between now if
you look on the far left of the picture
yes there is a double bond on the far
left but that double bond is between an
oxygen and a carbon so if you only look
at the carbon-carbon bonds you'll always
see a single bond here and so what we
what we mean by these fatty acids are
saturated what saturated means is that
it's just full with you know a sponge
can be saturated with water just means
that the sponge is full of water so a
saturated fatty acid is simply full or
saturated with is full of hydrogen atoms
and notice how the fatty acid is in a
straight line because the fatty acids in
a straight line you know one fatty acid
will typically stack on top of another
on top of another on top of another on
top of another and that's why saturated
fats typically are solid at room
temperature okay as I just mentioned
Sapir saturated fats tend to be solid at
room temperature you know here's two
examples of saturated fats butter on the
left and you may not be familiar with
lard because it's kind of been phased
out as a cooking oil but lard is very
similar in texture and consistency as
butter you know in in the olden days
people would cook with lard they'd scoop
up some lard plop it in a frying pan you
know turn the heat on let it melt and
then you would have a cooking oil you
know maybe for making fried chicken or
something but saturated fats like butter
saturated fats like lard are typically
solid at room temperature for the
reasons I just mentioned
you saw a moment ago the picture of the
saturated chain of carbon-carbon single
bonds because those are typically form a
straight line across you're gonna have
saturated fat stacked on top of other
saturated fats and a nice compact
stacking of molecules there makes them
solid at room temperature
these also saturated fats also typically
come from animals so the picture on the
left is our cow and butter is made from
cows milk the picture on the right is of
course pig and this is where lard comes
from lard is simply pig fat so now well
now let's look at a fatty acid chain
that we say is unsaturated and I hope
you see a few differences in the picture
well first of all we still see a long
chain of carbon bonded to carbon the
difference though is that we can see in
this picture I only drew one double bond
but some unsaturated fatty acids will
have more than one double bond in
between a couple carbons but we can see
that there's a double bond that exists
this is gonna cause the chain to be
crooked it's not straight across any
more and that crookedness I'll mention
the importance of that in just a moment
but that crookedness is supposed to be
there in the picture it's not a bad
picture or a typo or anything and the
reason we say that this molecule is
unsaturated because of that double bond
there's less space for hydrogen atoms to
attach remember carbon needs eight
electrons to be full and stable if you
look at both of those carbons attached
to the double bond
they each have eight electrons there's
four dashes attached to the carbon on
the Left four dashes attached to the
carbon on the right that's a total of
eight electrons there's no reason to
have a another hydrogen bonded to either
of those carbons that would give it too
many electrons it already has enough so
this is what we mean by its unsaturated
because of that double bond there's less
space for hydrogen atoms you might know
that the unsaturated fats are the ones
that are typically better for you there
not as unhealthy I should say so if you
try to limit your saturated fats and
maybe substitute some unsaturated fats
for those who are trying to be a little
health-conscious so unsaturated fats are
typically liquids at room temperature
and the reason is because of that
crookedness that you saw in the picture
a moment ago because of that double bond
it makes the chain of carbon-carbon
bonds a little crooked that spreads out
the molecule so that way one fat excuse
me one unsaturated fatty acid doesn't
really stack on top of another one very
well and that makes the molecule spread
out it makes them more liquid at room
temperature so examples of unsaturated
fats are typically plant oils you know
for instance you may have heard of
coconut oil I'm sure you know coconut is
a fruit grows on trees another example
of a of an unsaturated plant oil might
be olive oil you know we have red olives
on the Left green olives on the right
but again olive oil comes from olives
which grow in trees so these are plant
oils unsaturated fats are again
typically are the ones that are
healthier for you so if we just kind of
put a picture of a saturated on top and
an unsaturated fatty acid on the bottom
if we just count up the hydrogen's
really quick and see you can see the
hydrogen's being counted and 18 in the
saturated fat on top but because of that
double bond there's less room for
hydrogen to attach to the unsaturated
fatty acid on the bottom only 16 so that
double bond as I said earlier is going
to reduce the need for more hydrogen
atoms to stabilize the overall molecule
this is what we call an unsaturated
fatty acid on the bottom and on the top
it's what we call saturated because it's
full of hydrogen so one of the
applications of discussing lipids I want
to mention is that normally blood flows
freely in this case you see some red
blood cells flowing through an artery so
your hearts pump and red blood cells
around however
however person could have high
cholesterol levels in their blood and
over time you might get this buildup of
cholesterol this buildup of plaque and
it can harden and foot and form kind of
like a dam in a river and I hope you see
what's happening now as the red blood
cells continue to flow through the
artery they're kind of getting trapped
and clogged by that wall of cholesterol
there and so a normal healthy open
artery might be reduced 50% like you see
in the picture this is going to reduce
circulation cause blood clots and it
could even cause high blood pressure can
lead to stroke lead to heart attack so
you really want to watch your
cholesterol levels especially as you get
older and so the the medical condition
that I just referred to in that
animation right here is called
etherial sclerosis and so you can see on
the top a normal artery nice and open in
the bottom of the picture we have an
artery that's been closed maybe 50 55 %
with a buildup of that yellow plaque in
the picture so this comes from a
lifetime of bad habits you know this
doesn't happen because you've eaten you
eat McDonald's and you supersize your
french fries on a Thursday night this
happens over over a lifetime so you
really want to start if you have a
history of this in your family or if if
you have some signs of there are the
early signs of this you may want to
start you know talking to your doctor
about some some different lifestyle
choices you may want to consider and if
you are having your blood cholesterol
levels checked you know here's a little
table that might tell you whether or not
your cholesterol levels are high if
you're on the borderline of being high
hopefully you're in the less than 200
range
that's our desirable level of
cholesterol so there you go if you're in
my biology class pause the video and
answer these questions I'd love to check
them for accuracy either before school
or after school one day go ahead and
pause the video good luck